Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Cette chaise
n'est pas comme les autres.
Sa structure en métal a été upcyclée.
Nous l'avons sauvée d'une déchetterie.
Son assise et son dossier ne sont pas
faits de plastique ni de bois.
Ils sont fabriqués à partir
de déchets verts recyclés.
Cet éco-matériau, nous l’avons nommé Bosko
et nous le développons depuis
deux ans chez O’Nyme Studio.
Il nous permet de concevoir
des objets de design,
des objets de quotidien,
avec un impact environnemental réduit.
Cette chaise, c’est l’équivalent de
cent kilos de déchets verts recyclés,
soit l’équivalent d’à peu près
un mètre carré de bois préservé
et un premier pas
vers un quotidien éco-conçu.
Alors pour commencer,
qu’est-ce que le design ?
Le design est partout,
tout le temps, autour de nous.
Le design, c'est allier la forme
et la fonction d'un objet.
Il ne se cache pas,
comme on le pense trop souvent,
dans des objets froids,
luxueux et hors de prix.
Le design est dans votre chaise
dont le dossier vous accueille doucement
et où l’assise est à bonne hauteur.
Il est aussi dans votre lampe
qui se règle en fonction de vos besoins.
Mais le design est aussi
dans votre tube de dentifrice
dont le bouchon vous permet
de percer l’opercule de sécurité.
Seulement si le design
est au service de l’homme,
il est aussi au service de l'industrie.
Le designer conçoit des objets voués pour
la plupart à être produits en grande série
avec des procédés
de fabrication industriels.
Selon l’ADEME, l’ensemble des
équipements d’un foyer français
émettrait à sa fabrication environ
45 tonnes de matières premières,
tout en dégageant dans l’atmosphère à peu
près six tonnes de dioxyde de carbone.
Tout cela pour un foyer français.
La chaise sur laquelle vous êtes
assis en ce moment même,
c’est l’équivalent de 20 kilos de CO2
rejetés dans l’atmosphère.
Pour vous donner un ordre d’idée,
c’est l’équivalent d’un trajet
Paris-Blois en voiture.
C'est aussi le poids moyen d'un enfant
de six ans pour une seule chaise.
Le designer est à l’origine de ces objets.
Puisqu’il les conçoit,
puisqu’il les imagine,
il encourage donc
des problématiques environnementales
telles que la sur-industrialisation
ou l’exploitation outrancière
de nos ressources.
Ayant moi-même
des convictions environnementales,
mon amour pour le design
avait autrefois un goût amer.
Et j’encourageais -
et je dois vous avouer que j’avais
beaucoup de bonheur à le faire -
la destruction de notre environnement.
Chaque maquette, chaque prototype,
chaque objet que je concevais
générait d’énormes quantités de déchets.
Il a donc fallu que je trouve
une façon de produire autrement.
Fin 2019, je commence la rédaction
de mon mémoire de fin d’études
sur les nouvelles façons
d’allier design et éco-responsabilité.
Je découvre, mais vous
allez le découvrir aussi,
qu’il existe beaucoup de belles solutions
et que celles-ci se retrouvent
dans un seul et même concept,
nommé l’éco-design.
L’éco-design utilise l’éco-conception, qui
est un principe assez simple en somme :
il faut penser l’impact environnemental
de chaque étape
de la conception d’un projet.
Vous allez découvrir que de nombreux
designers, de nombreux créateurs,
cherchent à offrir un monde nouveau
où la création serait à la fois
pour l’Homme et pour la nature.
Avant de vous présenter ce nouveau design,
j’aimerais vous expliquer
comment il est devenu nécessaire
de créer cette spécialité.
Aujourd’hui, nous faisons face à
une importante crise environnementale.
Et selon moi, mais selon beaucoup
d’autres designers,
le design a grandement créé cette crise.
Il y a participé.
Après chaque épidémie,
chaque guerre mondiale,
nous avons toujours cherché
un retour à une vie plus douce,
plus facile et plus confortable.
Alors comment en est-on
arrivé à cette crise ?
Finalement, c'est de notre faute à tous.
Le designer a simplement répondu
à une population en quête
de confort et de rapidité.
Globalement, nous avons
de plus en plus travaillé.
Nous avons eu moins de temps chez nous
et il a fallu trouver des solutions
pour faciliter le quotidien
et notamment l’entretien de la maison.
Ainsi, briquets, verres,
assiettes, couverts, nappes,
tous ont eu leur équivalent jetable
plutôt que d’être lavable ou rechargeable.
Ainsi a commencé l’ère de l’objet-déchet,
ce fameux plastique jetable,
que l’on retrouve maintenant par dizaines
de milliers de tonnes dans les océans,
formant même de nouveaux continents.
Il se pourrait que d’autres
pratiques précipitent notre fin.
Je ne parle pas forcément de forage
de pétrole ou de déforestation,
mais d’une pratique qui est plus fourbe,
plus insidieuse, plus discrète.
Le greenwashing.
Le greenwashing vous fait
acheter du pétrole vert.
Il vous fait croire que vous agissez
vraiment pour l’environnement
alors que ce n’est pas le cas.
Qu’est-ce que le greenwashing ?
C’est une technique marketing
utilisée par une organisation
dans le but de se donner
une image faussement éco-responsable.
Les entreprises
qui utilisent le greenwashing
font semblant d’avoir de réelles
préoccupations environnementales
alors qu’elles conservent des pratiques
extrêmement néfastes pour la planète.
Imaginez-vous, vous consommateur
qui souhaitez changer
vos modes de consommation.
Vous souhaitez faire un effort.
Vous êtes donc au rayon lessives
de votre supermarché.
Vous cherchez une nouvelle
lessive plus responsable.
Vous vous tournez vers un bidon
dont le slogan est le suivant :
« La lessive pour votre linge
et l’environnement. »
Seulement une fois arrivé chez vous,
vous découvrez ça :
un logo corrosif,
preuve que cette lessive
ne peut pas être éco-responsable.
Si elle est nocive pour votre peau,
elle est nocive pour les insectes,
les poissons et les plantes.
Alors à quoi bon faire des efforts
pour changer vos modes de consommation,
puisque vous êtes trompé
par ce greenwashing ?
Pire encore, vous auriez pu
ne pas remarquer ce signe,
et continuer de financer
des modes de consommation
dont visiblement vous ne voulez plus.
Julia Faure, la co-fondatrice de Loom, une
marque de vêtements éco-responsable,
dit très justement que
le greenwashing est dangereux
car il nous décourage de changer
nos modes de consommation,
car il nous fait croire
que le problème est résolu,
car il nous endort
alors que la maison brûle.
Le greenwashing est également
problématique pour nous autres créateurs.
L’écologie pilote mes projets
et il m'est parfois un peu surprenant
de devoir les défendre face à des clients,
des consommateurs dubitatifs.
Le matériau que je vous ai
présenté précédemment,
j’ai souvent le droit
à des questions telles que :
« Et donc, c’est du plastique,
n’est-ce pas ? »
« Alors, c’est quoi le piège
dans ton produit ? »
Légèrement frustrant lorsqu’on se démène
pour créer des projets
réellement éco-responsables.
Seulement, je comprends ces questions.
Face à la flopée de produits
faussement écologiques,
vous êtes nombreux à devenir suspicieux
et à vous interroger
face à ces nouvelles solutions.
Mais sachez que c’est
la bonne attitude à avoir.
Cherchez derrière l’étiquette,
dénoncez les mauvaises solutions
et encouragez les belles initiatives.
Face à ce besoin d’éco-responsabilité,
nous autres créateurs avons
bien sûr notre rôle à jouer.
Il est de notre devoir
de faire des objets réellement
éco-responsables et honnêtes.
Mais rassurez-vous,
certains l’ont bien compris.
C’est le cas notamment
de Samuel Tomatis, avec sa chaise Alga.
Il s’est interrogé
sur les façons d’utiliser, lui aussi,
de nouveaux matériaux.
Il récupère donc des algues -
vous savez, celles qui se développent
beaucoup dans les rivières polluées -
et il les réutilise, les transforme,
pour fabriquer lui aussi
un éco-matériau utilisable dans le design.
Certains créateurs s’interrogent aussi
sur la notion d’objet-déchet :
les objets pas aux normes,
donc invendables,
les objets de déchetterie,
les rebuts du bâtiment.
Alexandre Estèves,
avec son projet Cumulus,
récupère, lui, des ballons d’eau chaude
qu’il transforme en mobilier urbain, mais
aussi en mobilier pour les particuliers.
Ces déchets retrouvent ainsi
une vraie valeur, retrouvent vie
et évitent la décharge.
Nous avons aussi des créateurs
qui ont décidé de ne créer
plus que pour la biodiversité.
L’Homme n’est plus au centre
de la recherche, mais c’est la nature.
Ici, le projet Refugio de MaliArts
s’occupe de cette biodiversité.
Cet ensemble d’objets totems
n’a pour cibles, pour utilisateurs,
que les oiseaux, insectes
et êtres vivants.
Chez O’Nyme Studio,
nous avons aussi à cœur de fabriquer de
nouveaux objets pour ce nouveau quotidien.
En 2019, nous avons conçu Haru,
un aquarium mêlant
aquaponie et phyto-épuration.
Cet aquarium n’a pas besoin
de filtre à charbon, ni d’électricité.
C’est uniquement l’équilibre
entre les plantes et les poissons
qui fait que cet aquarium
finalement reste propre.
Il est important de noter que dans
cette course à l’éco-responsabilité,
nous avons tous un rôle à jouer.
Vous, consommateurs, en refusant
les modèles que l’on vous propose.
Alors recyclez, réparez, dénoncez, votez,
mais surtout ne financez pas
les modèles dont vous ne voulez plus.
Vous, pouvoirs publics,
organisez des appels d’offres,
des concours,
pour trouver les nouvelles façons de
valoriser les déchets de nos territoires.
Comment peut-on être plus compétitif
d’un point de vue écoresponsable ?
Et nous, créateurs,
nous devons créer autrement.
L’éco-design ne devrait pas exister.
Le design lui-même
devrait être éco-responsable,
mais tant que ça ne sera pas la norme,
nous continuerons d’upcycler,
de recycler et d’éco-concevoir.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)